[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul aka the man of spoils
and we have a whole host of new
information about zack snyder's justice
league
the man giving updates so good i call
him crack snyder has just dropped a ton
of info regarding the project across
multiple interviews with multiple
youtubers
that aren't that aren't me i'm guessing
everyone's mother was named martha i'm
just kidding
and that's why i don't get interviews
however we've compiled everything you
need to know to give you the lowdown on
all the ins and outs of what we learned
from the information i don't want to
disgrace
myself eh so full credit to be on the
trailer the film junkie
and ping pong flicks for speaking to the
main man and getting this
amazing info out of him anyway i feel
like the first thing we need to talk
about
is the removal of the snyderka trailer
from all warner brothers social media
platforms
though the haters said it was because
the film was cancelled
it actually happened because of the
music hallelujah which has caused some
rights issues
behind the scenes things had not been
100 agreed
and this warner brothers had to rework
the contract so that everything was
above board
however as per the interview with ping
pong flicks zak said they will be
re-releasing the trailer
and also an additional black and white
one which he will break down on his vero
account
this is because snyder said he would
love to release a black and white
version of the film
which will probably save a ton of money
on making the superman suit black for
the entire film so
so smart move and that's why i don't get
interviews now i'm not 100
sure whether i'm going to release this
video before or after the release of
said trailer
but i am recording it beforehand zack
said there would be a couple of
additional shots in it to make it
something special
so that it wasn't just a re-release of
the trailer that we've already
completely seen
as he said there's only some extra
moments in the updated teaser
i wasn't sure whether it was worth
holding this video off until after it's
released
but if there's a lot more then i will be
doing a big breakdown tomorrow
zack is doing his own in-depth breakdown
so i don't want to just rehash
what he says but we will see anyway if
you hear from the future
and i'm too soon then there's a lot more
material in my bad
i'll get my clown costume on now today
is the anniversary of the twitter
revolution
released the snyder cut that actually
led to the release becoming a reality
throughout the day it's rumored that
we're going to be getting a lot of
surprises
so we'll of course keep you up to date
with any of the other major
announcements that i might have missed
anyway all that aside we do know that
the film is getting some additional
scenes
which will include jarrod leo's joker
zack told grace that he had a completely
different look for the character
and though it would be honoring what had
been created
there would be some major changes snyder
said that
some water had gone under the proverbial
bridge since the character's last
appearance
and that he's now a road weary joker
grace had actually seen the look
and stated that it was very video gamey
and i
of have some theories about what this
could be now full spoilers ahead for
what's apparently at the end of the
movie
so if you don't want anything ruined
then i recommend that you turn off now
also yes subscribe to the channel if
your mother's name's martha
and that's why i don't get interviews
anyway we do know that jim lee drafted
storyboards for the ending of the film
which showcased a five-year time jump in
which darkseid had invaded the planet
the only survivors left were batman the
flash
cyborg and some select others however as
we now know there are additional scenes
i actually think that the joker will be
there too i would love it if the pair
had put their differences to the side
and were having to work together in
order to save the world
this would be very video gamey in my
opinion explain why the joker looks so
road weary
and also open the door for spin-offs
which is another thing that grace
brought up
now as i said i haven't seen the trailer
yet so if joker is in it then i do look
stupid but who knows they could still
include some shots of him early on
before spinning off into this at the end
snyder said it was fun having the band
back together for this little vignette
and if it is a post-credits scene then i
think it would be a great thing to spin
off into the future with
with us knowing that the additional
scenes total in that full minute
it could also be that ben affleck's
return pops up at this moment
there is of course a return of
deathstroke who has dropped in to add
some more things
and who knows we might end up with a
nightmare universe in which batman and
these two enemies
are forced to work alongside each other
in order to help the greater good
superman is of course an enemy in this
universe so it does make sense that
there are a lot of people switching
sights
jarrod leo also of course wants a chance
to redeem his betrayal
after you know a lot of people were
disappointed in the last one
so i am hyped to see it as for the other
additional moments that were picked up
snyder did say that they would be very
minor and sprinkled throughout the cut
some media outlets have gone off on this
and said that the movie
is pretty much going to be exactly what
we saw in the theatrical version
but i think that's a really bad take the
theatrical one weighed in at two hours
and the snyder cut will be four so even
with the four minutes
you're still gonna get more than double
the runtime and material
that we saw in justice league plus we
have the scenes that zach
originally filmed which joss whedon shot
and i really feel like tony this is
going to be a completely different movie
zack stated that there are elements such
as barry allen coming to grips with his
father's situation
as well as victor dealing with his we
have these two opposing father figures
and their relationships with their sons
so there is a lot of material that they
can really delve into
snyder also said he directed ezra miller
through zoom due to the pandemic
whilst he was filming fantastic beasts
so
there are little things that they're
doing just to add some more life to the
movie
now when discussing the idea of things
changing with the cut
snyder confirmed that we are seeing the
version that they originally shot
and though some changes were made
slightly after the four hours will be
exactly what was filmed in england back
in 2016.
so the added scene will be a generally
host centric one
and zak stated that though drawings had
been done it was only now that they were
able to solidify it
sliders said this additional work was
super simple to film
which would be the case if it was the
nightmare moment i think
as the majority of this is on a green
screen
though it might not be as 2020 is
looking
a lot worse than this does now zach also
actually cleared up this moment in
batman v superman
and explained how bruce was able to have
the vision he stated that in his
universe when one jumps back in time
they create a vortex in which several
aspects of that reality
come through and these elements can be
projected through into the mind of those
in contact with it
the fact that it was brought up does
lend itself more towards my theory
and snyder himself stated that he
purposely shot the scene in bbs
because it would have massive
ramifications for the future
in addition to this across the
interviews there are other points that i
think
are massively interesting snyder also
said there would be seeds planted for
the future defenders of the earth
and this does tease towards the green
lantern and martian manhunter cameos
which we'll likely be featuring in the
show snyder said that the story would
continue heading in the direction
and they clearly set out all the way
back in batman v superman
as for the feature itself the director
did say that if he was asked to come
back and do more in his universe
that he would be interested however he
didn't have any expectations as of now
and that the bridge was far away in
regards to him returning to work on new
projects
snyder said he's happy that wonder woman
aquaman and the flash
were all branches of a tree that he
planted a long time ago
and that he's happy that these things
have come forth from the universe he
created
as for the release date we did see in a
recent tv spot that the series
will release in march 2021 but we should
be getting
a full date soon if it's not already in
the trailer
which this is why i don't get interviews
so the release of the cut is not too
long away
and we also had to confirm that it would
be appearing on amazon prime video
outside the us many people myself
included were worried about the
distribution of the project
purely because it was only labeled as
being on hbo max
which is exclusive to america however we
do know that amazon have picked it up
but whether it's releases the same day
that hbo max get it or a couple of days
after
definitely remains to be seen anyway
that's all the major new updates
and i have to say i'm even more hyped
for the release i know i've been moaning
about not getting an interview
but shout outs to the people that did
they're all big names in the snyderko
community
and i think it shows just how much zach
loves the fans that he went to the
people he did
rather than the big outlets that have
been downplaying and denying the project
existed for
for so many years now zach knows who
supported him
and as fans let's all enjoy the day and
the new looks
obviously i'd love to hear your thoughts
on the info and what you hope to see in
the film
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoy this video yet
just just drop a little thumbs up it
makes a big difference
and make sure you check out our
breakdown of last week's updates which
covered everything
we didn't mention here don't forget
we're giving away three copies of the
marvel phase two box set
and all you have to do to be on the
chance of winning is like the video make
sure you subscribe with notifications on
and drop a comment below
but when it's going to be chosen at
random on the 30th of november so make
sure you get involved
going to support the channel and get to
see contents early then please consider
clicking the join button below
you can also come check this on the
discord server linked in the description
or heavy spoilers on twitter thanks for
making it until the end of the video
you've been the best i've been poor i'll
see you next time take care
[Music]
peace
[Music]
you